and the sentencing of the father and his
partner emma tustin of uh arthur la
binjo hughes the little boy who was
murdered now emma tustin his father's
partner who's just 32 years old has been
sentenced to 29 years a minimum term of
29 years in prison for the murder and
cruelty of arthur his father that's on
your screens both of them there now
thomas hughes 29 years old has been
jailed to a minimum term of uh 21 years
in prison for manslaughter and cruelty
of his own son let's bring in sky's
midland correspondent lisa dowd who's
been following this for us at coventry
crown court uh
lisa you've been hearing some utterly
horrific testimony tell us what's been
heard in court today as far as the judge
is concerned and of course we've also
heard from the grandmother today as well
well the judge
said that this was one of the most
distressing and disturbing cases that he
had ever had to preside over and there
were a lot of tears in court
there were family members who were
listening to a victim impact statements
from two of arthur's grandmothers and i
must just say that the defendant emma
tustin had decided not to go to court to
hear her sentence the judge
took the court through
the catalogue of abuse that had happened
to arthur calling the behavior of the
defense and defendant spiteful and at
times sadistic he talked about it having
been locked down when arthur and his
father had moved in with emma tustin
in sully hull
in quite a hurried fashion um it was a
relatively new relationship and they all
moved in together arthur had been happy
and healthy and that is where things
went downhill
both defendants beat arthur
at times he was made to stand alone for
up to 14 hours a day
in a corner he was made to sleep on the
floor and we heard that emma tustin had
withheld food and drink from him and on
the day of his death had administered a
potentially
fatal dose of salt to the little boy
before inflicting a brain injury which
was akin to a high speed traffic
collision in force that is what the
judge said um he said that hughes had
been infatuated with tustin and it had
obliterated his love for arthur and he
talked about the haunting videos in this
case an audio of arthur that we have
seen with him crying out for help
crying out for food crying out that
nobody loved him and he said that tustin
had wanted hughes his father but not
arthur and the judge made comment that
neither of the defense defendants had
shown any remorse now we heard victim
impact statements from madeleine halcrow
and who was talking on behalf of
arthur's natural mother who was in
prison
at the time of arthur's death and she
said the arthur was her life her purpose
her reason for living and he was all the
best parts of her she said he'd been
excited to see her in prison but that as
lockdown happened contact had been
dropped with the wider family and arthur
was isolated she said he was let down by
the person he trusted and should have
protected him she called herself mummy
bear she called after baby bear and she
said sleep well my angel you are loved
we also heard from joanne hughes
arthur's grandmother on her father's
side she tried to flag up the abuse that
arthur was going through with the
authorities the abuse that her son was
part of and she pulled off her the
sunlight of our lives and she said
that
the arthur they knew was happy joyous
and exuberant
and she noted the complete lack of
remorse from emma tustin in this case
and she said that arthur had been failed
by the very authorities who should have
ensured the safety of everyone
and lisa you mentioned there a catalogue
of abuse and you also mentioned how
uh arthur's family said that he was a
happy healthy child when he moved in
with his father and his father's partner
thomas hughes and emma tustin
there is now a separate investigation
into how many chances to stop this from
happening
have been
missed yes there will be an independent
review of whether more could have been
done to help arthur and i can take you
through
a timeline of events that we heard in
court
on april the 17th
2020 social workers from solihull
council
visited arthur at emma tustin's home
after his paternal grandmother joanne
hughes reported seeing bruises on his
back
social workers say they found faint
bruises but agreed it was a happy
household and there was no cause for
concern now a week later arthur's
grandmother sent social services the
photos of the bruisers taken on the day
before their visit but it was decided
but it was decided that everything was
fine and no further contact was made
with the six-year-old now arthur's uncle
also sent the images of bruising to west
midlands police but officers concluded
they had no further role as social
services were already involved and then
arthur suffered an unsurvivable brain
injury on june the 16th 2020 and his
life support was switched off the
following day
now the iopc the police watchdog has
looked into how the police handled this
case and they have found nothing to
justify disciplinary action but they
have emphasized to west midlands police
the importance of sharing information
okay lisa thanks very much indeed thank
you